this video is kindly sponsored by hunter
killer
find out more later in the video hey 42
here
they say necessity is the mother of all
invention
and that maxim is never truer than in
times of war where a technological
advantage over your enemies
can be just as valuable as a numerical
one
for that reason many of the major
conflicts in history have led to
a flurry of important breakthroughs
radar
night vision goggles the jet engine and
nuclear weapons
were all perfected during the second
world war for example
but there's more to winning a battle
than simply having the best weapons or
the most soldiers the ability to
out-think your enemy
is just as important as outnumbering
or out-gunning them and out-thinking
your enemy
isn't just about flanking maneuvers and
getting to higher ground
in this picture you can see several m4
sherman tanks
a popular vehicle used by the allies
throughout the second world war
and a three-ton support lorry these are
serious tools of war and i'm sure your
average nazi would have thought
twice about attempting to storm this
highly strategic
cops of trees but you might be surprised
to learn
that the vehicles in this image were
built with
one serious weakness the nazis were
never aware of
a design of death star proportions
they could be completely and utterly
destroyed
with a single pinprick
quite often i can spend longer trying to
find something new to watch on tv
than i actually do watching it and
like many recently i've been watching
more and more
crime and murder mystery content and so
when i found hunter killer it's fair to
say
i was pretty excited hunter killer is a
murder mystery subscription box
and it's one of the most unique games
that i've ever played
with each delivery you'll sift through
piles of documents
evidence audio recordings and case files
eliminating suspects and identifying
murder weapons
until you crack the case and catch the
killer but hunter killer isn't just
about solving a murder
this game tells an immersive story
slowly unfolding over time
you'll learn about the backstories of
each of the suspects
they're complicated relationships and
watch everything unfold
as you complete each episode i had so
much fun playing through the first
episode
of the curtain call story when a body is
found in the attic of a depression era
art
deco theater called the cadence i was
called in to track down the killer
and find out what happened just imagine
your favorite murder mystery tv series
but you're actually in it a part of it
and
better yet you're the leading detective
you can actually touch and feel the
lifelike
props and clues that are supplied in
each box
and the best part is that right now you
can get 20
off your first box all you have to do is
head to hunterkiller.com
forward slash 40 and use the code
40 at checkout again use the code
40 for 20 off do you have what it takes
to hunt a killer you see these
apparently imposing war machines aren't
actually machines
at all they're made of nothing more than
rubber
and air a bunch of giant balloons the
allies used to
fool german reconnaissance planes into
believing
their forces were much larger and better
equipped
than they actually were and that's a
textbook example
of out-thinking your enemy using
military deception
in the first world war military
deception was used in various inventive
ways by both sides
this for example is a camouflage tree
and if you're wondering why exactly
anyone would want to camouflage a tree
allow me to explain choose a tree
somewhere out in the middle of no man's
land
found between two entrenched armies have
an artist create
a perfect reproduction of said tree out
of metal
canvas and print then under cover of
darkness
creep out into no man's land cut the
real tree down
and replace it with the fake one and
here's the sneaky part
the fake tree is hollow with just enough
space inside
to allow a spotter or two to hide in
plain sight
close to the enemy lines genius
camouflage in general has always been a
pillar of military deception
but one place in particular it's
difficult to implement
is out on the open ocean after all
there's not much point painting a
warship
blue when the very fact it sticks up
several meters above the endless expanse
of flat
ocean means it will be instantly visible
to enemy ships from miles away
british artist norman wilkinson solved
this little problem
with something he called dazzle
camouflage
if you've ever seen an optical illusion
you'll know just how completely the
human eye can be fooled
by the clever use of geometry colour and
patterns dazzle camouflage took
advantage of that fact by turning entire
warships into
giant optical illusions so as to make it
difficult for enemy ships and submarines
to accurately assess their speed and
heading
crucial factors for lining up an attack
run or torpedo strike
during the first world war literally
thousands of battleships were bedazzled
i mean bedazzled in this way
and the practice was used even as
recently as the second world war
speaking of the second world war the
allies global battle with the germans
and their axis buddies
took military deception to new heights
in fact it's no exaggeration to say that
deception techniques
had a decisive impact on the outcome of
the war
if you've been following the channel
recently you'll be familiar with the
story of operation mincemeat
an allied plot to fool adolf hitler with
a genuine
rotting human corpse but around six
months after
operation mincemeat was put into action
those sneaky allies were at it again
only this time they were cooking up a
far grander deception
in 1944 the allies were preparing for
what would become one of the defining
moments of the war
the invasion of german occupied france
the idea was to open up a new front
against the axis in europe
stretching their already taxed armies to
breaking point
but landing a large number of troops in
heavily fortified
northern france was going to be tough
not least because hitler and his
generals were well aware this attack
would come
sooner or later and so they built the
atlantic wall
a series of coastal defenses and
fortifications
designed to fend off a land invasion
launched from britain
but whilst it was only a matter of time
before the allies attacked
exactly where the invasion would take
place was a little less clear
there were four potential sites for the
landing brittany
the content contonton peninsula normandy
and the pacquiao
brittany and contonton were ruled out
pretty quickly
both are peninsulas meaning there was a
risk allied forces pushing into france
could be cut off from support on the
coast
the pacquale was arguably the most
sensible point of attack
being significantly closer to the south
coast of england than the other sites
but for that reason it was also the most
heavily defended part of the french
coastline
and so the allies decided to turn their
attention to normandy
which though a little further away was
less well defended
and offered an ideal entry point from
which to push deeper
into central france but storming
normandy against a prepared
entrenched army would be disastrous
inevitably costing the lives of tens of
thousands of men
which meant only one thing it was time
for a bit of
classic military deception the idea
was simple convince hitler the allied
invasion of mainland europe
would come at the pacqa before
actually landing at normandy but
achieving that goal
was going to be one hell of a challenge
with operation mincemeats the allies
used controlled leaks
the release of false information to fool
the axis powers
into defending the wrong location prior
to the invasion
of sicily but controlled leaks alone
simply weren't going to cut it this time
and the reason for that was proximity
calais
is just 20 miles from dover on the south
coast of england
and that meant german reconnaissance
planes had a pretty good view of what
was going on over there
on the other side of the channel a
full-scale land invasion requires a huge
army
scores of tanks hundreds of ships and
planes
and hundreds of thousands of troops for
an attack on pascale
that army would need to be stationed in
the southeast of england near dover
so if german spy planes reported that
dover was about as busy as your
average nightclub during lockdown hitler
would immediately know
something was up it was time to start
pumping up those inflatable tanks
because the allies were about to conjure
an entire field army
of more than a hundred thousand men
literally
out of thin air as well as inflatable
tanks
fake aircraft like this one were built
by the hundred
and positioned next to equally fake
landing strips
and various important looking but fake
equipment
the airsats tank aircraft and other
military vehicles
were all carefully camouflaged carefully
but not too carefully the allies needed
german spy planes to be able to find
them
after all but if they made it too easy
it might look suspicious speaking of
german planes and making things look
believable
british anti-aircraft gunners were given
an unusual assignment
they were to let german reconnaissance
planes
pass safely through british airspace
whilst making it
seem like they were trying to shoot them
down
fake tanks and aeroplanes are one thing
but what about the ships
an invasion force would need to be
supported by hundreds of landing craft
and unlike tanks inflatable ships
bobbing around on the water were
unlikely to fool
anyone even at a distance the problem
was
landing craft were big how the hell were
the allies going to make fake versions
of these beasts
that looked genuinely convincing from
the air
actually the landing craft in this image
are fake
these three were moored up in the thames
estuary just waiting to be seen by
german reconnaissance
planes in the lead-up to the normandy
landings
but hundreds were built in total they
were nicknamed
big bobs and were made from scaffolding
tubes
wood and canvas all floated on 40 gallon
oil drums they were delivered like giant
ikea flat packs from around the country
and could be built by a team of soldiers
in just six hours
and i'm sure you'll agree they look
pretty bloody realistic
i'm having a hard time believing they're
fake and i made this video
to complete the illusion of a huge
invasion force preparing for war
all these fake vehicles were
supplemented by a sustained campaign
of hundreds of thousands of coded radio
messages
sent all around the uk these signals
were
carefully designed to mimic the kind of
communications
you might see from a real field army
gearing up for battle
by this point in the war britain had
amassed a large number of double agents
that the nazis believed were loyal to
germany
and these two were mobilized on mass to
support the idea of an invasion in the
park alley
to put the icing on this giant fake cake
general george patton the allied
commander hitler and the axis powers
feared the most
was personally brought in to lead this
non-existent army which was dubbed the
first
united states army group or fosag
patton known as old blood and guts had
established a fearsome reputation
in various battles in the mediterranean
earlier in the war
and he was exactly the kind of heroic
commander
the enemy would expect to lead the
invasion of france
now it might seem like a bit of a waste
to put a man like
patton in charge of an army that didn't
exist
but unbeknownst to hitler and co patton
had actually been temporarily removed
from battlefield command
at the time for slapping two battle
shots soldiers
after the invasion of sicily giving
patton commander fuzzag
allowed the allies to make use of his
reputation
whilst he was otherwise out of action it
also probably didn't hurt that
non-existent soldiers can't get battle
shocked
and they don't much mind being slapped
in one final sneaky
brilliant act by the allies a german pow
being sent home
not long before the invasion was led
through what
he believed to be kent in the south-east
of england
which he saw with his own two eyes was
swarming with
troops tanks and supplies in reality the
british had taken the man
through hampshire and what he'd actually
seen
was the real invasion force that british
general bernard montgomery
was about to lead to normandy this
multi-pronged deception was collectively
known
as operation fortitude south
and it was a truly colossal undertaking
involving masses of resources and a
giant
chunk of wartime cash but boy was it
worth it
just picture the evidence hitler had
been presented with
reconnaissance reports suggesting a huge
gathering of vehicles of war
near dover an observation that was
corroborated by
multiple unrelated german spies and many
weeks of radio evidence
even one of his own soldiers the
returning prisoner of war
backed up the story and he'd actually
been there
the allies even went as far as to
apparently
soften up the paid calais in the weeks
leading up to the invasion
with targeted bombing runs of defenses
and key infrastructure
whilst leaving normandy almost entirely
alone
in the face of this overwhelming
evidence the fjora concentrated the bulk
of his forces
at the pei calais so when a hundred and
thirty thousand or so allied
troops landed at normandy on the 6th of
june 1944.
it came as a bit of a shock the battle
was still
incredibly bloody with thousands of
allied troops losing their lives that
first day
the location of landing hadn't been
anticipated but normandy was still part
of
the atlantic wall and was therefore
defended to some extent
in spite of the losses d-day as it has
become known
was a huge success giving the allies the
footholds they needed in mainland europe
as for operation fortitude it was so
convincing that even
after the allies landed at normandy
hitler was still expecting
a second invasion force led by general
patton
to rock up at the pay calais any day now
and so he continued to maintain heavy
defenses there
for a good four months after d-day
buying the allies precious time
to fully establish themselves in france
the allies may well still have won the
war without operation fortitude
and the army that didn't exist but
there's no doubt
that by fooling the germans countless
lies were saved on d-day
and beyond and hey that's not bad for a
bunch of tank-shaped party balloons
and some floating scaffolding thanks for
watching